[Music]
hello welcome to our scintillating
episode of what's in the box I'm dr.
Jekyll mr. Hyde it got long it took for
him to get that one okay man we can't
start [ __ ] show till a box gets open
man so yeah look at that cut second nice
come on there Bryan Adams and feel so
right now nah nah like a girl diving in
a pool there you go
Oh Riley we're gonna see some [ __ ]
equality on the show god damn it cuz I
saw this right here all right man in
honor of the daredevil series which is
[ __ ] amazing yeah we're looking at
the daredevil you think one man make
difference take your shot
in this season of daredevil you can have
not just daredevil as represented in
three Daredevils here but also a lecture
at nine away and also Punisher Frank
Castle to play by John Baron foe I need
to take care of the scum that killed my
family this I'm baffled as to why these
were included other than just to make
this more fun somehow their caps like
bang bang back you put them in a gun you
don't have a gun now
oh we do right here dude the old toy biz
Marvel figure had a cat firing weapons
so you could literally [ __ ] fire caps
in his back let's do it yeah focus
welcome this let's open this
[ __ ] first okay man toy biz was
a toy company that made figures of the
Marvel characters at one point Marvel's
like destitute that got no money to pay
this dude back they buy Marvel toy biz
ball yes and the Marvel that you know
today is built on the foundations of
[ __ ] that little logo right there toy
biz and that crazy I can't remember if
this was controversial or not how could
this have not be controversial
this [ __ ] fires caps you know what's
gonna make a Punisher figure more fun
kids gunpowder's make sure we're doing
it right you got to open this feed it
through the box will fit right there is
bunghole we just say I don't see
anywhere answer god damn it give it to
me most kids probably don't remember
caps man I bet you caps skipped a few
generations that's [ __ ] gunpowder man
you put enough caps together you can
take out a wall they'd never do that
these days man they give you [ __ ] like
lasers here to take down a helicopter
but they'll never give a Gunpowder here
I think I got so it comes with a tommy
gun and Uzi alright put one in this hot
little hand alright cool and let's see
if we can get this [ __ ] even let's see
if we could have the fun we've been
promised alright here we go boy I smell
it I smell it a smoke I saw smoke that's
the smell and sight of 70s fun with a
90s toy I had this figure I bought this
store bought like three times in my life
I don't know if anybody knows because I
wrote a little one in the early days toy
biz would do figures that like nobody
gave a [ __ ] about the only problem is
like you know they're like
daredevils billy club no it's not
there's a goddamn [ __ ] bazooka right
there it's a wrestling I know and it
says extended billy club yeah there's
nothing Billy or Club --is-- about this
man oh this is some malarkey bah it's
not all it's cracked up I'm losing
against this fight I look at this [ __ ]
ready yes trying to launch a launch
doesn't even working look he's got one
arm to arm the head moves three points
four and the knees one two three four
five six seven points of articulation
but you didn't care back in the day
there's this billy club it's painted
onto him you didn't care back in the day
man that you weren't looking for
articulation you were just like I can't
believe they made a daredevil figure
that's nuts it went off in my hand
this might have a first girl harm said
to me what it won't work old school toy
biz which I fully support when I look at
that I see our childhood when I say
childhood I mean our 20s I got special
connectivity to this if this is based on
the Ben Affleck daredevil
a movie that I was in I was in the spa
you know mayor it's always done I
couldn't believe I literally could not
believe they would make it as dirt
a flick called me up he was like they
offered Matt Damon dared up but Matt
past what an idiot he goes they offered
it to me and he was like yeah but
[ __ ] I always wanted to be Batman and
I was like dude they never didn't do
Batman again and Tim Burton to find a
Joel Schumacher broke it and [ __ ] that
ain't gonna happen you should do [ __ ]
daredevil so he's a guy anyone did dirt
over and they wound up doing baton few
times yes and he actually is employing
it did you ever make a froggy foggy
Nelson froggy froggy froggy froggy there
we go oh my god get the name right I
don't know if they ever made a foggy
that would have been a jon favreau
figure could you imagine having a jon
favreau action figure so you could
[ __ ] play you can get your Vince
Vaughn from Jurassic Park to figure and
you could finally play swingers you're a
bad man you're a bad man you're a bad
man look at him you could tell the Tim
oh yeah he had his head scan for
everything I remember when he had his
head scan he gave me the heads to happen
on my shelf his little daredevil head
that he got says Kane you trained me to
billy club yeah i have the billy club
hang in my man cave
we have famous friends we have famous so
look okay look at old school daredevil
you can't open this [ __ ] hand this
guy let's count his is when they get to
this daredevil like ten years later
let's count the points of articulation
one in the head two in the arm three at
the elbow for at the wrist five at the
fingers six seven eight nine ten he
could twist like chubby Checker's 11 at
the leg 12 at the leg 13 at the knee 14
the lower leg twist 15 at the foot 16
the toe then you got to add 17 this leg
18 19 20 there's at least 20 points of
articulation on this figure and you need
for my Cantor may do with the Star Wars
figures with like arms and legs and
heads
that's five technically but by the time
you get to been a flat man he needs way
more points of articulation he's like
I'm an articulate actor give me lots of
points of articulation
did you see good good day gentlemen and
until that day comes
keep your head of the grindstone that's
why I like the GI Joe with the constant
grips GI Joe had this movement so when
you played and you're fighting with your
Jose yes you could do this Star Wars you
can only go it'll start where's your
license what's better that's true that's
true but [ __ ] easily pushed off a
position like if you believe it stick
with it man you were just so dick
animated you were like a guy's [ __ ] eyes
kung fu grip and I'm like yeah but
that's horseshit yeah I guess you're
right
stick by your [ __ ] Lord your beliefs
demo you like Star Wars and some people
in real will come up to him below you
know what Kevin Smith sucks
you're like yeah this is [ __ ]
incredible I'll be honest with you more
fun playing with this the most people
had seen the movie today look at that
like yeah man guess what if you're not
feeling this body you could feel like
the [ __ ] metal Stan's body right here
power metal Stan so this is like not
from the movie this is not meant to be
Jen garner now that's meant to be Ben
Affleck but this is a cartoon that's
more this version this is the most
recent dirt on this one has one two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven twelve thirteen fourteen well I
don't like to Hank the nunchucks they
did kind of they did kind of skip yeah
when it came to the billy club you can't
put the billy club in his sidepiece
where this one you get put him in the
side mm-hmm if you put him over that
cross looks like covers a joke aside a
book that I wrote that Joe came with a
comic book that's just smart he's gonna
buy a toy he might as well include a
comic book with it maybe get the kid
hooked on reading and first taste is
free
Otis a nice reprint man he's got Black
Widow in it and stuff this is good this
is good this is a story about battlin
Jack Murdock now his dad died and it's
got the old cop
look at at the old yellow and stuff and
then I bet you that show here into the
red and they do they put to have them in
the red as well
Roger McKenzie was the writer Frank
Miller was the artist this early Frank
Miller work right here good story man
still a tearjerker we've got old
daredevil new daredevil we got old
Punisher where's new Punisher oh hey oh
new [ __ ] oh no man maybe this dude it
comes with a backdrop piece oh that's
some good stuff it matters tavern this
is like a full-on
diorama Diamond Select Toys makes this
one now this looks like a Punisher based
on like a Tim Brad Street pleasure oh
snap son look at that you get a bonus
figure with this figure as long as your
idea of play is like this is what he
always looks like hey let's go save
these cats make a fine [ __ ] tour dude
they got a tall dude spider-man pinball
machine oh me he's a grenade in his
mouth dude he's got thug for life tattoo
look at this Punisher man compared to oh
you know one way bigger also it's like
if this dude showed up he's got a smile
on his face look at him this
[ __ ] shows up at you dad oh god
i'll suck dick - leave me alone please
look at this gun belt dude that's pretty
impressive the detail this is [ __ ]
astounding let's see hold on one to the
head turns three maybe he twists the
four five that's it and maybe his feet
yeah this ain't even a figure it's more
of a statue mmm maybe his fingers move
no so I count five points of
articulation or his body look sick he's
twisted the hips yeah six six I have
more articulation than this Punisher all
right oh wait we can do this - oh sure
here before you blow them up let me take
care of something
you better stop sucking him off or I'll
shoot your ass you say stop doing that
father this is why they won't give us a
Marvel movie dude because that
oh just my balls are like a grenade what
I'm in there son oh look at that said
only ass matters to matters tavern way
to take superhero relics and turn it
into fellatio in a bar I'm not even done
unpackaging the toy you've already had
an adventure oh there's a secret station
they got and that's where all her
weapons goes we put the oh do you think
how great that is that is pretty amazing
hey you can hang it on the wall drink or
just buy it and then you're like I need
some weapons oh snap that's pretty
impressive maybe you can even put her
adjustable bar it's also could be look
cuz bra in the comics chances are you
like comics kids you like for color
comics the next color you're gonna like
is green you get older you love weed
this is where you hide your stash oh and
in your hand on the wall no one will
think to look in their room smells like
we know my friend smokes weed mom but
really you're hiding it right there
under a lecture and a lectures
protecting it she's lonely brain is
electric not use my name's elektra
natchios fluid all these fabulous prizes
let's go old school dude toy biz
classics right yeah man its original
retail price dude what do you think they
went for back in the day should remember
you bought many of them or rather I
should say you made me buy many of them
for you I would say $4.99 what are you
packing yeah even back in the doll 8
9999 no man it's 999 999 SS introduced
by toy biz in 1990 you could get them
now though these two bad boys on eBay
Amazon how much you think dolly and I am
come on no hero goes for a dollar 99 it
was more value than that to a hero 5 to
8 bucks I can pick them up now for 5 to
8 bucks you can have a non cap working
figure as well this Punisher with
homeboy in the pinball machine
yes that's based on the Punisher max
series written by the great Garth Ennis
what would you pay for this punisher
playset right here when I use the term
play loosely as it only has six points
of articulation I would say $19.99 no
you'd have to fork over a little bit
more just in touch more 409 in Jack
$24.99 that's absolutely right
what would you pay for a lecture not
just my name is Elektra not you I would
say $21.99 that's that is uncanny
you got it Oh 21:9 you know if you look
it up that's worth it right there ready
for the apartment yes alone for the
storage capacity and last but not least
of course the Ben Affleck version of
daredevil all right I'm thinking it's
sort of the same you got the wall piece
no hiding spot though but I would say
this is probably a 1995 piece close to
more bucks and be yours $21.99 yeah
Bonnie Bates still grabbing stuff how
much you think that daredevil on the
cross goes for $14.99 you're absolutely
I have no idea I'm gonna say you're
absolutely right thanks probably there's
somewhere in the world you get this for
$14.99
I bet usually going to a shop and
there's an old Asian man who's like
never feed at after midnight hey what
I'll do I'll give you $100 you'd sing to
him at night and that'd be like me
selling you somebody comes in the stash
and they're like oh my God all the Jay
and Silent Bob toys are gone what can I
get my kid now be like well how about
Jay himself and they're like how much
dad I'm like don't a not tent tent I
wait for the reaction on their face
twelve twelve thousand get you up to 12
K all right just for you know knows I
did you load me
[ __ ] yeah and they treat you well you
treated like a goddamn pet like gizmo TZ
give me toys yes and the cool thing is
like they could feed you after midnight
yes and get you [ __ ] wet they can
they can they can put you in the Sun
yeah no doubt you get all me and feel
like get me wet right now like why I got
to turn it into more guys and I got well
if you get me put the wetness in the
right place I'm talking about babies and
that's your version breathless there it
is bald somehow we've gone through
everything in the Box man it comes to
the conclusion
daredevil comes in many shapes and sizes
including the Netflix series which like
I'm ready to watch right now man what
else would you like to see us open folks
write to us man let us know go to
Facebook you go to a to Twitter you go
wherever you've got a write down below
there's an address that you can email us
at let us know and the screen junkies if
you can't reach us leave a message with
the screen junkies men let them know
what you want to see us open on the pin
the box here on what's in the box until
next time on what's in the box I've been
Kevin Smith Kissimmee Ruiz and that's
that man what's in the box was a bunch
of cool their double [ __ ] haha
[Music]